des particuliers qui ont pas le droit
des avoir et qui sont débarrassent au
bout d'un certain temps parce que un
perroquet comme ça ça vit 80 ans
ici on a un hectares ici et on en est
dans des prairies en dehors aussi que
nous prête on a replacé beaucoup
beaucoup d'animaux la tanière c'est plus
de 3500 animaux sauvés depuis le départ
c'est un hôpital c'est une maison de
retraite solution d'accueil pour les
animaux qui n'en ont pas qui n'en ont
plus ça peut être une tortue ça peut
être un éléphant à Lyon intime des
ânes c'est un peu les restos du cœur des
animaux ici il y a toujours le JT le
couvert pour un animal
ça c'était la première vidéo qu'on a
fait avec brut il y a un peu plus de 2
ans à l'époque les animaux influent
étaient en train de prendre conscience
de tout ce qui allait nous arriver on
est passé au cauchemars on était au bord
du gouffre on aurait pu se casser
complètement la figure que les bébés
des œufs pour les singes pour les ours
aussi et à 15 jours trois semaines on
était vraiment au bout de bord du
gouffre ici on vit de sources de revenus
pour 55 ans à peu près les entrées du
public on est avant tout un refuge
faisons refuge pour des raisons
économiques et 50% les dons les deux
nous permettent d'équilibrer normalement
s'il y a pas de covid s'il y a pas de
guerre s'il y a pas de canicule à toutes
les éléments dont on peut dépendre et
puis quand on tourne la clé ici tous les
matins ça coûte 20000 euros s'il se
passe rien de spécial malheureusement il
y a beaucoup de gens il se passe des
choses spéciales on doit partir en
intervention on doit faire des
opérations de la mobilisation c'est du
personnel c'est des soins ce qui nous
importe c'est le bien-être l'animal et
puis de lui donner après une vie qui
soit meilleure que celle qu'il avait
la cuisine centrale donc il y a trois
personnes très cuisine centrale à chaque
fois il y a l'animal ou le nom d'animal
dessus sur les plats d'ici ce soir ce
toutes les gamelles qui sont là vont
être remplis il y a un tableau où il y a
les utiliser c'est à dire que
c'est soigneurs qui l'ont monté à
celui-là et bien les champignons donc
celui-là il veut pas de chou-fleur ça va
pas être super donc on a plus que des
animaux qui ont eu des problèmes on
donne que du très bon à manger on donne
un petit peu de récupération de quelques
supermarchés mais assez peu ça
représente 5 à 10% du total
alors on est livré on est livré tous les
jours en fruits et légumes donc voilà ça
c'est déjà des plats qui sont prêts pour
certains animaux le blaireau porc-épic
etc il nous faut ici deux centaines de
fruits et légumes par an la nourriture
représente
4 à 5000 euros par jour il y a environ
700 animaux à nourrir ici à ceux qui
mangent des fruits et légumes ceux qui
mangent du poisson la viande et aussi
ceux qui mangent du foie un éléphant par
exemple ça mange 100 kg de 3 par jour le
budget alimentation doit être un peu
plus d'un million d'euros par an depuis
quelques mois notre coût de
fonctionnement a augmenté de 45% environ
25 à 30% ce qui concerne l'alimentation
300% sur l'électricité puisqu'on avait
une facture d'énergie de 90 000 euros
par an on est passé à 360000 euros
de la viande du poisson
c'est plusieurs dizaines de tonnes aussi
par an on a des gros gros fauves des
gros lions qui mangent jusqu'à 15 poules
par jour ou l'équivalent en viande rouge
donc 25 kg le poisson c'est cher aussi
les otaries il nous faut 150 kg de
poisson par jour
à côté des otaries entre les otaries et
le groupe de filtration là il y avait
une barrière qui est complètement tombée
sur les 90 personnes on a une douzaine
de techniques
que ce soit paysagiste soit à l'atelier
des soudeurs que ce soit électricien des
gens pour la maintenance les animaux
souvent ils n'ont pas grand chose à
faire dans leur parcs ils passent leur
temps à casser tout ce qui se présentait
que vous aviez sous-estimé frais etc on
n'a pas sous-estimer on a été abandonné
dépassé par la demande de placement au
début on devait faire simplement un
refuge et c'est pour ça qu'on a ouvert
on publique parce que on s'est dit voilà
nous on a mis l'argent pour construire
tout ça avec mon épouse on a mis
l'argent de notre première vie et
professionnelle on avait 30 millions
d'euros mais ça avait pas qu'on retourne
animaux et on veut essayer de pas dire
non au maximum l'ampleur du phénomène a
été dix fois celle que ce qu'on pensait
et on découvre qu'il y a un besoin
énorme dans le sautage animaux on
aimerait bien être rejoint par d'autres
et il y a plus de 100 en France si
chaque réseau prenait 400 animaux ça
nous ferait beaucoup de bien
heureusement les gens ont été là
derrière nous les gens nous ont suivi
les gens continuent à nous suivre
continuer à nous faire des dons il y a
deux trois semaines on était vraiment
pas bien on avait une restait encore un
trou à bouger de mur et demi d'euros on
a enregistré une vidéo qu'on a lancé sur
les d'abord sur les réseaux sociaux
cette vidéo on a vu on a lancé cette
vidéo à 18h30 le 18 février
aujourd'hui on s'adresse à vous l'heure
et l'heure est grave à la tanière pour
les banques comme pour beaucoup de gens
dépenser de l'argent pour sauver les
animaux c'est ça vaut pas la peine donc
soit on va se casser la figure là dans
les jours et heures qui viennent soit
grâce à vous on va s'en sortir alors
nous on a on a tout donné du ma voiture
ma collection de vin on a hypothéqué
notre maison
et j'ai regardé les vues à 400000 euros
on a pleuré
on n'a pas endormi de la nuit et c'était
le cas pendant les 10 nuits qui ont
suivi on
suivait ça de très près et quand j'aurai
après on avait réuni ces deux millions
de vidéos c'est une très belle histoire
c'est une chaîne de solidarité
extraordinaire c'est la force du public
c'est de c'est le bon côté des des
réseaux sociaux on entend trop souvent
parler des mauvais côtés des réseaux
sociaux la preuve qui a aussi des côtés
merveilleux dans les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]